des textes pensée est couché sur le
papier en 2015 il n'y a pas de lait qu'a
voulu transmettre ses pensées ses
émotions sur les événements tragiques
parisien j'ai pas écrit ce recueil pour
un public spécifique mais c'est vrai que
je pensais c'était un petit peu
difficile pour un public collégiens et
ils ont choisi sansan de connaître en
fait pour ça que c'est encore vraiment
plus plus important puisque justement
ils ne me connaissent pas et c'est
vraiment le texte qu'ils ont choisie
pour ce prix les dia pas de lait qui
était face à trois autres ouvrages avec
un jury inédit 350 collégiens saint
quentinois
tout d'abord on a étudié la couverture
et on a classé enfants d'affaires
classement provisoire des libres
on avait le plus insolite nommé le mois
et après on à entrer dans le vif du
sujet regardez ce qu'ils avaient dans le
livre c'était sympa de faire appel à des
collégiens pour fort à la poésie parce
que souvent balles et les jeunes ébahis
l'aps pas vraiment la poésie et faire
appel à des jeunes bat c'est quand même
assez original on en apprend beaucoup
des du poète enfin franchement c'est
génial oui moi j'ai beaucoup aimé comme
ça j'ai découvert la poète et beaucoup
de libre le prix collégiens lecteurs de
poésie d'aujourd'hui existe depuis trois
ans piloté par les itinéraires poétique
qu'il vise à diffuser la poésie
contemporaine
les ouvrages ont tous été édité
récemment fait un choix dans tout ce
qu'on reçoit ce ne sont pas des livres
destinés à la jeunesse c'est ça c'est
voulu et on fait un choix qui permet de
montrer une l'éclectisme delà de la
création poétique mais aussi
l'éclectisme de l'édition poétique à
travers des ouvrages de forme va dire de
toucher différents aussi un travail
réalisé en cours ou lors d'ateliers les
collégiens ont aussi réalisé des vidéos
autour des textes étudiés 14 classes ont
participé à cette troisième édition
[Musique]